we're going to be looking at uh just in
time compilation which is a technique
for making programming languages run
faster so we all want faster programming
languages because then we get more speed
and there are various ways we can do it
so we can statically compile things
that's typically done for languages like
C or we can just in time compile them
which is often done for languages like
Java or JavaScript and the difference
between these two is that just in time
compilation is looking at the program
running and optimizing it after it's
observed it running so just in time is
really a terrible name because it should
have happened before you you actually
got to that stage but that's the name
we've got and it's a technique that you
will all have used today if you've used
a browser you're using a JavaScript
just-in-time compiler
and they're sometimes considered a bit
magical so I'm hoping we can look a
little bit at the magic
I'm digging the idea of magical
computing
so I mean there's no Wizards I don't
have a beard uh and I kept the cape at
home today actually to disambiguate
something that people often confuse
people often talk about compiled and
interpreted languages and there's no
such thing so
for any given program language you can
implement it as a compiler or an
interpreter or a just-in-time compiler
so people say C is a compiled language
but you can and there are C interpreters
and people say JavaScript is a an
interpreted or just-in-time compiled
language but you can write a static
compiler for it as well so what do I
mean in the sense by those things
um so a static compiler reads A
programming just looks at the code the
program is written and then tries to
convert it into machine code let's say
an interpreter uh looks at the program
and then it
um doesn't convert into machine code it
kind of executes it almost as is it
probably converts into some other
representation but it's a very simple
way of implementing a programming
language
and a just-in-time compiler nearly
always starts a program running an
interpreter looks at it for a while says
things like oh look you're calling that
function a lot or there's a function
that takes some parameters in and
they're always integers always strings
so I will now produce an optimized
version of that functional part of the
program based on that information I've
observed
and it's really that Dynamic analysis
and conversion into machine code at
runtime that makes just-in-time
compilers very effective they can be
faster than a static compiler because
they've got more information so if you
just look at a program at compile time
you've just got the code you've written
on screen
you can can't fully analyze it as much
as you want so you'll make certain
assumptions and guesses but they may be
incomplete or even Incorrect and you'll
optimize based on that when you're
actually running the thing you've got
more information so you can make a much
better quality optimization but you've
had to watch the program and observe it
so it started slow and then hopefully
over time it's hopefully it's warmed up
is the term and then it gets faster
warming up turns out to be another
kettle of fish it doesn't always quite
work as we expect these things have some
very surprising emergent Behavior but
generally they do work and when they do
work they can be very effective so this
is things like uh it knows you're kind
of again alluded to before it knows it's
going to be calling this this function
quite a bit so it keeps that nearby and
things like that is that it can do those
sorts of things maybe we could try a
little simple example so if I log in
so what I'll uh it's just a simple
example so there's a load of these that
I could use the Java virtual machine to
adjust-in-time compiler the JavaScript
VMS all of the ones V8 and chrome spider
monkey and Firefox and those are all
jits but I'll look at one for python
because um that's one that I happen to
know fairly well and
let's just write a very silly little
Python program so I can write this
function let me make a little bit of a
bigger font size for you and it takes
two parameters in and I will just add
those two parameters together thing is
am I going to pass it integers strings I
can do all of the above let's just check
that I'm not lying because I do
sometimes
sometimes intentionally but mostly
unintentionally but if I do hello world
I have to have a space in there if I
save that file
and then right so it prints out five or
hello world so you can see I'm calling
the function in different ways so this
is why it's hard to statically optimize
that function because integers strings
it can take in all sorts of things
now the normal implementation of python
which I'm using here with the Python 3
binary is an interpreter doesn't have a
just-in-time compiler and we can see
some obvious consequences of this let's
put this in some sort of loop so I'll
just put some very big number here that
looks like a big number to me and just
repeatedly call that function with some
integers it doesn't really matter now if
I run that and I'll just call it with
the time function and I'm going to say
this is my newish laptop that has from
memory 6 fast cores and eight slower
cores and the it's going to run randomly
on those each time I do it so some of
the performance numbers are not going to
be quite as clear-cut as I would like so
I'll try and explain it if I see that
happening
so I run that and it's taken that a
tenth of a second to run and if I make
that number a lot bigger so I make it an
order of magnitude bigger this for Loop
it now takes a bit longer and if I make
it longer again
we'll see depending on which style of
core it's gone on I think it's yeah it's
roughly gone on the two slower cores
it's it's roughly as I make the loop Run
10 times longer the program is taking
roughly 10 times longer to run so that's
what we'd expect soon to interpreter now
let's get rid of a couple of those zeros
and what I can do instead is use a
different implementation of python and
this is one thing that we often confuse
we say python when we mean the language
and there's python the language and
there's python the implementation I can
use something called Pi pipe and I'm it
has a jit let me turn the jit off
and hope that I've not made it run too
slow
so we can see that running and I've
still got a relatively large number so
it's about the same speed as the normal
version of python now we'll turn the jit
on
and it now runs in well that's a tenth
of a second it has run two orders of
magnitude faster and in fact I think
we'll see if I've got this right let's
add another couple of zeros there
something very big
it actually doesn't really matter how
big I make that loop it's been able to
observe it at runtime realize it can
just optimize the whole thing away and
that's the power of just in time
compilation it's looked at my runtime
values and made the thing very fast it's
particularly effective on this sort of
numeric code but it will often work well
on things like strings and so on and of
course there are some cases where it
won't work it isn't as we said earlier
magic but it is very effective in many
cases
so as you scale up
um is that is there still a benefit to
using it you know when you've got a
million lines of code for instance good
question
um very dependent on your program in
fact in some sense actually the scale of
it is less important than the nature of
your program
there's a fundamental assumption here
that programs tend to do the same thing
over and over again so in this case Pi
Pi is looking for loops and it's what's
called a tracing just-in-time compiler
so it looks at what the loop is doing
and optimizes that there's also method
base which just look at a function don't
need to worry about the difference too
much
if your Loop or your function does the
same thing repeatedly with only minor
variations this will be very effective
if you have a program which uh every
time it goes around the loop does
something completely different or every
time you call the method then this will
be less effective in some cases then it
will even slow things down because the
program will never appear to stabilize
and that's really what your expecting
programs do is that they typically when
they start up they do some
initialization that's all a bit random
and then they tend to hit some sort of
main part where they do the same thing
over and over and over again and that's
where jit compilation really comes to
the fore and our process is doing a bit
of that anyway
you yeah so I think of our modern
processes it's basically a just in time
compiler I write machine code and okay I
like the textual form and it looks like
armor x86 or whatever that's not what
the processor eventually executes it
turns that into some other
representation it does all sorts of
clever optimizations if you ever want to
see things uh like the store um the way
a processor optimizes program reorders
it like the reorder buffer they're scary
at how clever they are and that's why
they've got a lot faster even though the
gigahertz part hasn't changed too much
and there's been a little bit of
knowledge transfer between the the
processor jit world and the programming
language world is this a new thing or
how long have these kind of just in time
components been around them
they have been around in one form
another for a while but they really
Trace their modern lineage back to the
1980s in a language called self which
has been largely forgotten a really
interesting language that had a
just-in-time compiler via a long
sequence of events that ended up going
to a company called sun and is then
formed the basis and literally some of
the code is still there in the Java
virtual machine so the Java jit traces
itself back to self
V8 the JavaScript VM and chrome also
traces this lineage back to the Java
virtual machine hotspot and back to self
so really that's been those have been
the um the big movers and now you've got
systems like Pi Pi and V8 and spider
monkey that have
um modernized the concept or spread it
to more languages would probably be a
better way of putting it and is this you
know obviously it traces it through it's
quite a long way back but is it only
really being used now because machines
have got that much faster
yeah I think there's there's an element
of that
um because for you when I was a kid you
could buy a new computer every 18 months
and it was twice as fast and the the
death of single core performance is a
little exaggerated partly because the
processes are now doing just-in-time
compilation sorts of things but yeah we
definitely are looking increasingly to
programming languages to work faster and
for many languages particularly but not
only those that are Dynamic type like
python or Java this is really the only
effective technique and we and that's
why you've seen increasing numbers of
them being released for more and more
languages despite the fact that they're
really complicated and expensive to
create you know these are not the sort
of things you can knock out in an
afternoon they take some big teams many
years to create in most cases
train a network to undo this process
that's the idea and if we can do that
then we can start with random noise a
bit like I can and we can just iterate
this process
die a b c and d
and I tell you that die a has a value of
four
how much did you learn about the data